[Music]
my mom used to like to tell the story
that when she would play tennis with me
i would purposely just try to hit her
with the balls
[Music]
she scolded me at one point she's like i
think you're trying to hit me tony
i'm not going to play with you
the new hbo documentary tony hawk until
the wheels fall off has no shortage of
thrills but also shows a more vulnerable
side of the legendary skateboarding
champ his superstar status was affirmed
at the oscars last month when he
appeared with surfer kelly slater and
snowboarder sean white all considered
icons of their sports but that doesn't
mean they're super human our jamie wax
met up with hawk at the half pipe where
an uncharacteristic fashion hawk
recently
fell and broke his leg
so
exactly two and a half weeks ago yeah
i was doing my twist right here oh
and
um i don't think i had enough speed and
i
thought that that would be okay yeah so
i didn't get the full spin that i needed
and i still tried to force it on the
wall and i got tangled up and ended up
crashing pretty much right here
in the world of skateboarding
we expect to see tony hawk make nothing
but perfect landings
[Applause]
but a new hbo documentary
starts with the legendary skater
repeatedly unable to land a trick
i was willing to get hurt along the way
but i didn't visualize myself getting
hurt along the way
how open were you to to showing like
these these moments of falling and also
these deeply personal details that are
in this documentary the skating to me is
just that that's what i do so i don't i
didn't really think of
that being of great interest i chose to
try to do a 900
well probably wood frizz for the last
time it took a little bit longer for me
to get to it than i thought
and there was a lot of crashes and he
went through it
in real time and no one had really shown
interest in doing that because who wants
to see a bunch of bales sam jones did
the respected photographer and
documentarian is the film's director at
a skateboarder himself why did you
choose to open with that when we think
of tony hawk and when we've seen tony
hawk
we think of those moments of triumph and
we always see tony
landing these tricks and doing
incredible things and what i think gets
lost in that sometimes is how hard it is
how much work it takes how much
dedication how much pain you go through
and that footage when we first looked at
it was so compelling it told us so much
about his heart
sure you can show humble beginnings
and determination and things but i feel
like that struggle has carried me
through all the way to my adult life
the film documents the early days of
skateboarding and how tony hawk's family
helped him find what he was meant to do
they tried all these sports and all of a
sudden your brother brings you to a
skate park and you say oh maybe this is
it kind of yeah and when i saw what was
happening at the skate park that's when
my mind shifted on what this is this is
like a daredevil it was like i was
watching evil knievels all over
but something that was tangible to me
that i could figure out
and that was when i decided that i was
going to do that and nothing
else he was clearly talented and
determined but because of his size he
did things differently part of what we
know
as skateboarding as a professional sport
comes from you figuring out what to do
once you got airborne because you didn't
have the athleticism or the strength of
the guys who were doing it before you i
wasn't trying to create a movement i was
i was just trying to figure out how to
get airborne like everyone else
and the only way i could do that was to
launch myself into the air and then
grabbing my skateboard late those days
it was considered very
weird avant-garde
they said it was cheating i can grab it
every which way and do these things in
the air isn't that a good thing and you
know that was one of the things that
drew me to tony from the beginning and
when i learned how to do that
not only was it more efficient it was
way more fun
yeah
it's such a
incredible feeling
that's when it feels like you're like my
i was always chasing the feeling when i
was a kid of flying because i saw people
flying i was like i want to fly
i mean really i remember the first time
i ever caught my board late grabbed it
and landed and i was like
i just flew
i'm never going back
and he never did thanks to the help of
his father frank who launched his career
and legitimized and organized the sport
which was both a blessing and a curse
for young tony at first i didn't really
care because i'm just stoked that
we had an event that we're all going to
get together at and then as i sort of
rose through the ranks
and then there was these these
whispers of favoritism and then outright
you know
accusations against me
but that didn't stop him he went on to
compete every chance he could
career gave the world many incredible
moments like this one when he landed the
very first 900 at the 99 x games
[Music]
and again when he was 48.
no matter how deep i dug into tony's
life i found that at the heart of every
thing he set out to accomplish or every
impulse he had
there was this drive that
he wasn't ever going to let his
himself down by not
by not working the hardest he's an
ambassador to the sport and continues to
be this day
skating is what he lives and breathes
his passion was on full display at the
film's premiere
what do you want people to take away
from this
i hope that at the very least it
inspires people to pursue their passion
and to know that the hard work is worth
it
and also that
skateboarding is for everyone
you know it is
all you got to do is get on the
skateboard you're in and that's exactly
what he did 28 days after the accident
he put his cane aside and grabbed a
board something he will surely ride
until the wheels fall off
for cbs saturday morning jamie wax vista
california
[Music]
the hbo documentary film tony hawk until
the wheels fall off is available now on
hbo and on hbo max and he is
53
years old
still doing that amazing
i cannot get over the feats of the human
body when the spirit
is just soaring and he loves this
and wants to continue doing it how do
you push through after injury and what
and he because he's talented but also
it's that hard work he talked about
wow
love that tony